[Music]
all right guys congratulations it is now
down to the 2u to battle it out figure
out who's going home with the title of
fortune fire champion and a check for
ten thousand dollars in round three
we're gonna be sending you guys back to
your home forges to work on this blade
for four days the blade we're going to
have you guys build is this
[Music]
the william wallace sword
bigging right
armed with this gigantic two-handed
claymore william wallace was known for
leading the scottish rebellion against
the english during the late 12th century
measuring in at a staggering five foot
four inches tall the blade weighed less
than six pounds making it both
lightweight and long enough to deliver
deadly blows against the enemy on
horseback or on foot
wallace led his troops to victory with
his namesake sword during the famous
battle of sterling bridge memorialized
as a scottish hero wallace can be seen
wielding his iconic sword in the 1995
blockbuster braveheart
this is the largest sword we've ever
asked any blade smith to make one look
at that beautiful sword and i think
nope
you've got to make your blades within
these parameters the blade length needs
to be between 51 and 53 inches with a
blade width no less than two inches you
guys need to have a guard with up swept
quillians lingerie and two side rings
need to include a two-handed handle and
top it off with a pommel the best of
luck to both of you guys we'll see you
back in the forge in four days
[Music]
here we are round three championship
round let's try this bad boy out and big
challenge making a big sword i've made a
few swords but never have i made
anything of this caliber that's a 32
inch blade
i need 20 more inches
the key to victory with a weapon this
size is performance
and it's all about that heat treat that
is the most critical part yeah oh that
looks great
i like it i like it i like it
just a little fire just a little farther
it seems to have taken break
i am
excited
that went wonderfully oh man i'm feeling
great this sword is enormous and it is
light i want to wield this thing
there's not a lot of reasons to walk
around town with a chainmail shirt
unless you have a william wallace sword
then of course you should have a
chainmail shirt on
that's pretty nice that cut really well
i'm back in bloomsburg pennsylvania my
home forge i got to make a william
wallace sword
it's a beast of a sword
today i would like to get the blade
drawn out to rough parameters hopefully
i can't screw this up i only have one
piece of this
so now that i've got my rough shape
formed in i get the angle grinder that
way i can look for d-lamps and cracks
looks good i don't see any cracks
i have to get this quench done
here we go
i'm just worried about something going
wrong with this because it takes way too
much time to make this and i don't have
enough time to do another one
get in there
come on
got a little bit of a warp in it but
it's not bad
i'm pretty happy with it
it's time to start putting all the
pieces of the sword together
i slipped the guard down on my sword and
the challenge just making sure
everything fits tight and there's no
wiggling there's no moving because if
they hit it off something and if
something loosens up i could go home
i'm really happy with the way it looks
big sword for a big guy all right
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
iconic william wallace swords will do i
will take your sword and deliver lethal
blows on this wild boar carcass
james you're first you ready for this
yes i am all right let's do it
those hogs can take out a weapon pretty
easily it could wrap around the side of
the hog instead of cutting into the hog
and all that momentum could go into
bending the blade rather than slicing
into the pig
and that makes me very nervous
all right james talk about your blade
here pocket knife it is not
but this long blade actually has a nice
weight to it it's wieldable with two
hands
grabbing on to your handle here i get a
good grip your edge is razor sharp it
easily punctures and has a nice draw cut
to it now cutting the carcass as you can
see it cut it in half and more
importantly sir
you'll kill
thank you sir all right lyle your turns
are you ready yes sir let's do it
my stomach is just in knots
i'm nervous about my quench and you know
i'm just i didn't know if i did it right
but i'm gonna find out i'm ready for it
to be over
alright let's talk about your william
wallace sword here it's a lighter sword
it's about a half a pound lighter your
edge is sharp now it cut very deep on
this big carcass didn't cut it in half
but it did cut
overall sir your sword
you will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our battering ram chop now
why would you attack a battering ram
with a sword
i don't know but we're going to do it
anyway now remember this test is not
about what your swords do to that
battering ram but how well they hold up
james you're up first you ready dave i
hate this plan
all right james
blade is still true as it was when we
started it's comfortable it's strong and
man it held up well good job yeah i
really like hearing you talk about it
that's great
all right lyle your turn ready i guess i
guess
hey
all right lyle first off uh remarkable
job making a weapon this big this light
and hold up that well that that's
impressive but the issue is
we've got some loosening going on
other than that you did a great job
thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test the foam pillar slice now
unlike the strength test this is all
about how sharp your weapons are and
what they do to these foam pillars that
are wrapped in leather james you're up
first you ready yeah man let's go let's
do it
all right james
the edge of your sword
is like cutting through butter
it's a nice clean cut cuts all the way
through overall sir your weapon
it will cut
thank you
all right lol your turn sir
you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
all right lyle's talking about your
sword here um first up
the guard is still a little bit loose
from the strength test but when it comes
to the cuts it is a sharp edge that you
have here it did cut the leather it just
didn't cut through it's a lighter blade
thinner edge over here but
it does cut thank you
all right gentlemen you guys both
brought us back giant william law swords
that exceeded our expectation they are
the largest swords ever built in this
competition so we want to commend you
guys both for that
but there can only be one champions
competition
and today's fortune fire champion is
james congratulations thanks lyle
unfortunately you just didn't make the
cut today and dave baker's going to tell
you why
lyle you made us an amazing sword that
performed very well but that guard
loosened up in the strength test and it
just didn't cut as well in the sharpness
test and that's why we're letting you go
i understand
lyle thank you for all your hard work
you produced a phenomenal weapon but
unfortunately i'm gonna have to ask you
please step off the floor thank you
i'm a little upset that i lost but at
the same time i mean i i got nothing to
be sad about
to be here at the finals and my sword
actually made it through i mean
i can't be more happy about it
[Music]
james congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion you'll be leaving
here with a check for ten thousand
dollars how does it feel pretty great
yeah baby i'm forging fire champion
great work
feels a little surreal like maybe this
isn't real you might find out tomorrow
that this didn't really happen
[Music]
you